how do you feel president biden is doing
so far oh
awful tell me why almost couldn't be
worse
go right down the list
the masks
well first of all the fact that
he basically thinks he's king
for
everybody for every decision
the fact that he thinks he can tell
schools what to do
uh the fact that he's given fauci so
much power
that he's shutting down businesses that
he's uh printing up money handing out
checks i i i can't think of anything
he's done right the only thing that i
would have done that he did was withdraw
the troops
but i certainly wouldn't have taken
the soldiers out first and left the
civilians that doesn't even make sense
so the one thing that i agree with him
on he totally screwed up i i can't think
of anything he's done right what did you
like what trump did did trump do
anything right
yes he did
reduce some regulations
um
he
yeah reducing regulations reducing taxes
now of course you know the debt and the
um deficit we're getting into obama
territory but
uh
yeah
deficit oh and and
i did like his pick for the supreme
court which one which one
amy
yeah um i like
i
i would have a hundred times picked her
over our most recent one if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]